Several years passed and then Sinbad went on another voyage.
One day, they came near an island.
It was a beautiful place and Sinbad walked about on it for many hours,...
...then he was tired.
He lay down and slept for a while.
When he woke up, he was alone on the island.
The ship and the small boat were nowhere to be seen.
"They forgot about me," Sinbad thought.
For many days, he walked about the island.
He met no one.
He was completely alone.
Then one day, he saw a large dome on the ground.
"What is it?" He thought.
"It is smooth and there is no door or window in it."
Then, he heard the sound of a great wind.
Suddenly, the sky above him became dark.
Sinbad was standing beneath the wing of a huge bird.
The bird was a roc.
The dome was the roc's egg.
"The bird will soon fly away," Sinbad thought.
"It can take me away from this island."
He climbed onto one of the bird's legs and tied himself to it.